montag der 24 sagte es ist 12 uhr 32 und
die zeit ist für uns gekommen gibt zelte
in berlin abzubauen
wir fahren weiter nach hamburg adrian
ist gerade jetzt ein paar kleinigkeiten
einkaufen für die fahrt und die die
wohnung wieder bis zu bestücken dass für
die auch ohne hinterlassen packard noch
die letzten kleinigkeiten wenn das alles
erledigt ist dann hüpfen wir ins auto
und machen uns auf den weg an die elbe
heute wird's besonders spannend denn ich
habe nach wie vor keine ahnung wo ich
schneiden soll besonders in hamburg
nicht berlin kann sich ein paar leute
aber in hamburg endlich einfach
niemanden wollen niemanden der die
schnitzer früher und heute
internetleitung also wenn wir
wahrscheinlich wieder auf der autobahn
twitter post verfassen
und hoffen dass die leute darauf
reagieren und damit machen ja es wird
noch zu sagen gibt man sagen
denn
mehr
alle caches place lady
die caches brett
vw losfahren gibt es noch einmal eine
runde pizza hier in berlin
als abschiedsgeschenk leute werden wir
leider ein paar probleme hier
weiterzukommen weil ein fahrzeug sich
leider entschieden hat spontan anfangen
zu brennen
deswegen sieht es hier gerade so aus wir
stehen im stau aber hey das leben
mission eis lebt ein leben kopf immer
noch müssen sie das überlegen wie wir
uns die zeit rumtreiben
und ich hab da so eine kleine idee
die leute jetzt noch ohne spaß macht so
was aufwändig ein bisschen dumm von mir
muss ich sagen aber gut gestand die
ganze dämpft auch wenn wir gesehen dass
sich nicht bewegt hat wie andere leute
die ihm auf der fahrbahn herum also
warum nicht auf der fahrbahn
danson vor allen dingen wenn sich dann
der stau auflöst
viele kennen ja den regentanz was
hinterhand zwar das jetzt mit dem an den
stau auflöst vielleicht der tanz für
fließenden verkehr
da geht so man will dass leute seht ihr
das
essen man punkt komm ich bin überall
überall auch in hamburg
so leute wie sie jetzt kurz vor hamburg
hier sieht man die aktuelle zeit der
jagd nach zehn minuten ca wir haben
allerdings noch keinen schlafplatz und
wir haben noch keinen platz wurden
videos schneiden und hochladen kann
das ist kein stress nicht lösen das
problem keine ahnung wie aber misst
sogar gar nicht wo wir hinfahren aber
hier gut verfolgt erst mal nach hamburg
kommen angekommen in hamburg wir sind
ein paar schritte vom auto weg gelaufen
da wo es abgestellt haben suchen jetzt
gerade noch nach dem hotel
aber was gefunden
wert wird telefoniert wird jeder von new
york ist in warschau noch etwas finden
gerade eben zwei stunden land ein hotel
in hamburg besucht und jedes
doppelzimmer kostet hier einfach wenn
man noch ein auto abstellen will minimum
60 euro jetzt haben wir ein hotel an der
reeperbahn gefunden ja davon erstmal
instanz zu sein und so langsam wird auch
mal hotel finden das möchte ich gerne
zeit irgendwie umkamen
der weitere plan ist dann dass adrian
sich zwar kurz legt der ist klasse
gefahren ist müde aber heute abend kann
man feiern gern hamburg aber wir das
machen das wird sich noch zeigen des
gesetzes wir sitzen gerade in einem pkw
aufzug
du hast mal rausfahren weil wir
natürlich stellt dass wir unser auto
brauchen
den haben wir uns gefunden erst haben
sie gesagt ja wir haben stellplätze
hinter dem haus gehen dahin kein
stellplatz schon ein bisschen rost steht
hier richtig krass da muss schon gedacht
okay mir doch nicht zu wissen weiter
nachdem es schon bezahlt hatten nur
gemeinsam noch tief gerade jetzt fangen
wir im pkw aufzug ist klar damit 20 22
wir sind in hamburg angekommen am hotel
nachdem wir um 14 uhr losgefahren sind
und am 35 13 uhr fällt über also auf
jeden fall sehr knackig läuft auf jeden
fall bei dieser parkgarage hier guckt
euch das ja an richtig dass man filme
für den ausgang überhaupt nicht wir
dachten wir müssen jetzt einfach noch
mal hoch fahren mit dem auto okay tür
geöffnet
notausgang steht darauf man sieht so aus
alles klar
ich stehe einfach erbärmlich so heute
wir sind in der unterkunft wir haben
jetzt gerade eben etwas gegessen
sie müssen die beine vertreten anja
heute nur gefrühstückt dann zeige ich
mir kurz wie die bude hier ein bisschen
abgefuckt aber gut es ist halt auch
relativ günstig und wir sind direkt auf
der reeperbahn ist links und rechts von
unserem hotel sind einfach in stripclubs
da sind avi sex haus oder so
630 euro sehr gut sieht so aus ist jetzt
definitiv keine ritz carlton aber jetzt
schon im sommer kurz und dann gehen wir
mal raus und gucken was in hamburg an
einem montagabend zugeht
heute ist der 24 glaub ich und wir
versuchen zumindest die straßen hamburgs
bisschen uns jetzt machen wir müssen
planen wir haben jetzt auch zwei stunden
gezählt haben uns über alles mögliche
informiert darüber wie der währungskurs
zu dänischen kronen zu schwedischen
kronen ist und so weiter und so fort und
darüber was wir hier in hamburg machen
wie gesagt wir auf der reeperbahn
deswegen gehen jetzt darauf den
hamburger berg so ist als waffe
vielleicht noch in den golden pudel ist
ein techno schuppen
da freut sich vor allem der kleine
adrian ganz besonders ich glaube aber
dass ich die kamera dahin nicht
mitnehmen weil es einfach zu chaotisch
werde
und weil ihr richtig angst und die
kamera zu verlieren habe ich mir gerade
ist geholt das will ich nicht riskieren
deswegen würde ich sagen heute 24 jahre
august vierter tag vom roadtrip sagen
wir für jetzt schluss damit die fäuste
ich ein bisschen feiern gehen könnte ich
es ihr denn